uh we got a super chat here from akis
and he says uh conservatives had taboos
but these taboos presented meaning for
society's existence liberals replace
those taboos
with their own but stripped society of
meaning prove me wrong
there's not wrong as a conservative yeah
it's uh
conservative is a made-up word what do
they call it but it's consistently
conservative ever conserved
yeah exactly i mean like even the
conservative parties in canada they're
not conservative they're
they're left-leaning you know liberals
they just call themselves you know
conservatives the only party here that's
that's you know upholds freedom
you know sovereignty low taxation and
all sort of stuff is
is basically a libertarian party in like
the ppc but nobody votes for them they
have they have no seats in parliament so
they're not going anywhere i mean it's i
think the only
right troops are the muslims
well even they struggle like i still
deal with one-on-one calls i had one
yesterday you know with a guy
that's a muslim that lives in saudi
arabia and you know he's still
dealing with like feminist narratives
that are starting to infiltrate
you know the arabic world as well so
even guys in that culture
are starting to deal with like the
transition that we've had here for years
over there yeah it's a global thing it's
not women aren't changing the
environment's changing
same thing saudi arabian guy in mind
he's as soon as he stopped being the
trad con guy his life got instantly
better
and he's amazed at how many like young
married girls are just slipping out for
like
quick dick and then going back to their
traditional muslim families
and sterling's right there to catch him
he's right there to make sure
dare you cappy
[Laughter]
look one thing i want to chime in here
real quick with uh
kind of backtracking a little bit but
uh we talked about you talking about
like women being like i'm generally
being like unhappy
or perceived as unhappy and worse than
society and i said i just spent a bit of
time in ukraine like
every woman i came across there was
happy like and the like the male female
dynamic is like
intact like men can be men women can be
women they understand their roles and
they're happy and they're grown with
those roles
and it was kind of interesting this one
thing you don't see
in the west anymore and you i was seeing
it everywhere in the ukraine
is that you'll see like nines and tens
like super hot women
just walking around in the mall
sitting on a park bench like they're lit
they're not like they're all waiting
around
to get asked out on a coffee date
basically that's what that's
highlighted
yeah they're waiting for a guy to come
up and talk to him and it's not like but
i thought to myself for saying like why
don't i see this in america and the
reason you don't see this in america is
because one
they're all working career jobs so you
go they're not sitting around during the
day time they can't go out on dates
and two they're all hungover all these
american chicks are all like hung over
from like going to the club then
on a friday saturday night sundays
saturdays during the day they're [ __ ]
wrecked
they're just sitting there like either
hung over from dick or hung over from
alcohol
dude in america and if you look at all
the look at all the media now right look
at all the music and stuff like when we
had when we were younger
and when cappy was in his twenties you
know we had uh the spice
girls right right at least they were
like
not they were like sexy but they were
still kind of cute and stuff
now every music video the girls are just
[ __ ]
they're just like they're strippers
who who wrap lyrics that were written
for them
yeah horde has become a standard in
america like
you look at modern english a cardi b
music video today would have been
considered pornography in the 1950s
yeah yeah it's real funny because i mean
if you go back to the 80s there was a
big
push with the parental advisory uh stamp
on heavy metal
and i mean like if you use the f word
then
uh tip or gore would would try to get
your album taken off the shelf and blah
blah blah but today
it's you know you've got some obese land
whale that's basically stripping telling
women
that you know this is the way to live
their life
that i don't hear anybody trying to you
know trying to quash that narrative
that uh and that showed the the the
sales people
when when she started putting the
parental advisor stickers on things the
sales went through the roof right on all
of those albums everything they tried to
censor
ended up selling magnitudes above what
they were before
so like i mean like the interesting part
is [ __ ] we're like oh okay we just need
to keep pushing that
envelope and keep making money but i
mean like all of the lyrics that
that they were pushing on those albums
was about mental point of origin right
you don't like me fu yeah right
now it's like gangsta right your thought
dance around be
huge and enormous hey philip you
rich that was brilliant do that you're
going to become a millionaire then
they'll go
somebody's going to meme it if i dance
around like this right
you can't fault them it works right if
it didn't make money
now i think that's the issue everybody
likes blaming the external issues
not realizing that we're kind of
actively incentivizing it
people are watching cardi b so cardi
like a stripper is famous because people
are watching strippers because they want
to watch it
and i think a lot of the things that
trad people miss is like
how good was your system when people are
given it as an option and they decide
they'd rather go with the stripper
yeah there's zero reflection there
here's a problem that facilitates this
this with
women at younger ages i mean the amount
of work that i have to go through
as a parent to filter out this crap from
a child
the amount of filters i have to put in
place on wi-fi on
apps on mobile devices monitoring stuff
it's like off the chart nonsense because
they're getting hit hit with it
as soon as they have access to a screen
it's coming at them at
you know 150 miles an hour it's like a
freight train right
so they get so they start devouring the
stuff if you don't do something as a
parent
and put some kind of a wall between your
kid and this nonsense
yeah it's funny being a good dad seemed
to have worked for you so far anyway as
far as i can tell
you've got a great family actually
actually caring about the upbringing of
your child this is a [ __ ]
i know it's a wild concept wanting to do
it yourself instead of outsourcing it
my brother my brother does the same
thing because like he he watches
all of this his son's like cartoons and
stuff because even though
they start indoctrinating you because
this this leftist agenda and it's like
psychotic left this agenda
has led into all ports of media
including children's media
right and this is what goes for my kids
and this is why the the future is china
because china is like
actively banning that stuff out of their
country
actively going into their their their
weibos
their wechats all their micro blogging
uh
websites and everything and actively
banning feminism
actively banning feminist accounts
they're like because this [ __ ]
is eroding the american culture and
they're smart enough to do it
the only reason america doesn't wise up
and pump the brakes on feminism because
they they suffer the same problem that
all americans do they don't want to
[ __ ] lose the money it's
it's profitable to make these women
insufferable
is this tick tock still primarily owned
by the chinese
dick talk what a lot of people don't
seem to realize is yeah tick tock world
war
ii china's invaded and if they've
invaded through social media
and these social constructs this is war
i want to hear john's take on it because
i mean he's there in asia but i have an
observation generally speaking with tech
talk
so one china china is using tick tock
to okay so the big problem we have here
on social media is with
youtube instagram uh facebook when you
release something only a percentage
of your uh followers receive it and if
that percentage of the followers let's
say 25 percent of them
receive it receive it well like we press
like we place everything because how
many people
have like been like oh rich i didn't get
a notification for you being live or
your new video right
only if you meet a certain metrics in
the algorithm then do they open the
gateway
for the rest of your audience to get it
if the content is deemed good
china just has organic discovery on
tik-tok they give people what people
want they just want
views they want clout they want people
to see them so they give them
give that to people but what they're
doing is they're inserting a lot of
propaganda in there
as well tick tock is not tick tock is
not
what's used by chinese people there's
doing which is the
um the chinese tick tock that's a
separate tick tock used for china
and then tick tock is developed for
outside of china so the tick tock for
china is different
than the tick tock we use even though
it's they're both chinese owned
so they are definitely pumping
propaganda into america and if you look
at the growth rate tick
that's why that's why youtube came out
with shorts why to compete with tick
tock that's why instagram came out with
reels why
if you don't post once a week a reel on
instagram right now you're punished in
the algorithm
okay so that's why they created that as
well to compete with tiktok
so let me just show you something
because i notice it's because i just
repurpose content that my editor creates
for me and then i upload it to
twitter instagram and tech talk it's the
same content i mean i don't use tik tok
i don't follow anybody on it it's it's
it's just a pla place to post
to to obviously get the attention and
hey you know there's some larger or
longer form
format content but i've been shadow
banned so
if you go and search for my tick tock
it'll show
no no uploads whatsoever it looks like i
actually deleted my account
to the public but you can see all the
uploads that i've been posting it's like
one or two or zeros as far as view but
like prior
to that you get like 60 000 there's a
few back here with a quarter million
half a million
you know as i kind of go back more but
tick tock promotes
content i mean if you look at the 4u
page or the home page
there's a lot of um like feminization of
the western mail there's a lot of
pacification of the western mail
they're like the chinese i believe
anyway are are actively
participating in the weakening of the
west
they're suppressing this content which
gets rich on other western platforms
still you know for some reason but
on a chinese owned platform they won't
show you anything now
that promotes mental point of origin put
yourself first you know masculinity
stuff like that
very very interesting oh i got i got a
clip for you rich if you want to play it
i'll send it to you
in the private chat this is something
that that is
in the history of uh conflicts
you know the the winners usually come in
and they castrate the males they put
them in dresses they make more makeup
they make them
grow their hair long they feminize them
that way they're not a threat anymore
the romans made their their operating
procedure
when you're trying to conquer a a new
territory
the romans made the their their the
people that they
conquered they made the boys be raised
by their mothers
i mean like on the home page if you're
looking at
tick tock feeds i mean there's guys that
are like oh yeah cuckoldry is fine i'm
okay with like dudes you know
like chad coming along and and smashing
my girlfriend or my wife there's nothing
wrong with that you know it's a modern
way that we do things here because of
love and all that sort of things like
dude this is abused
this is ultra cringe but i just sent it
to you rich it's a it's a minute long
but it's basically
you could if you can't see the
propaganda in this i mean
why don't i throw it up on the screen
because this is not copyright stuff so i
can show it so you guys can see it too
i'll get ready to cringe oh yeah this is
weird
yeah this is coming from the libs of
tiktok um
page which was one of my favorite today
i just have a laugh at this nonsense
um let me go audio
can you guys hear this keyboard colors
too
could you guys hear that audio yeah okay
let me just play it from there
this is the type of stuff i show my kids
and be like do not do this this is
propaganda
boy watch me be a man who has all the
feels i can laugh
cry sing and still keep it real i don't
have to be
tough like they have no rhythms
the choreography is just
why can't pink and purple keep what
colors too
i feel better macho men won't wear
sparkles
boys wearing pink [ __ ] hats
are so patriotic
[Music]
that's so toxic i'm a feminist boy
all right i'm going to vomit my mouth if
we carry on with that but i mean like
you get the idea
of what they're pushing in feeds and
what they'll show i mean again
i talk about put yourself first don't
deal with you know toxic women
you know stuff like that but something
like this will get pushed right at the
top of the feed because they run the
algorithms right so they want to show
that to
western viewers
you